[Music]
the price of lithium has been going
through the roof
why
because it's the key ingredient in
rechargeable batteries used in
everything from smartphones to electric
vehicles and as governments and
companies increasingly move away from
carbon fueled economies those batteries
are in higher demand than ever traders
and companies are betting that there
won't be enough lithium supply to meet
demand in the years ahead there's
actually a lot of lithium available all
over the world most current production
comes from chile in australia while the
extraction process is relatively easy
converting it into battery grade
chemicals is tough
producers are also facing environmental
pushback
[Music]
these factors have electric vehicle
makers worried that they won't be able
to secure enough of the metal and that
could hinder the transition to a low
carbon future
the future of transportation in our
nation and around the world is electric
as big automakers like tesla ford and
general motors increase production of
electric cars demand for lithium is
multiplying
analysts expect the size of the lithium
market to more than double by 2025
but right now supply is tight
once lithium is mined which itself can
take a long time it's then sent to
places like china where the metal gets
converted into the chemicals needed for
batteries china is the world leader in
processing these battery grade chemicals
so that's a major concern for u.s
companies and politicians but you can
also see how shipping this stuff all
over the world creates a very cumbersome
supply chain
still companies and investors see
lithium as a huge market opportunity as
the transition to a greener economy
picks up pace because some people are
saying that lithium could be the 21st
century version of oil and that securing
supply is so important you see a lot of
companies really trying to invest and
produce and that race is really playing
out everywhere because again lithium is
abundant it's just about getting it out
of the ground
and finding a kind of low-cost way it's
more sustainable way really to convert
it into battery grade chemicals
as more companies get involved in
lithium production analysts expect total
supply from countries like australia and
chile to eventually exceed demand and
cool the price rally in the coming
months and years
mining giant rio tinto is one of the
many players getting involved in the
lithium market
the company recently announced an
million dollar deal to buy a lithium
project in argentina
but projects all over the world are
being met with opposition
[Music]
in serbia in december 2021 we saw a lot
of protests and thousands of protesters
in belgrade blocking bridges to protest
rio tinto's plans to invest over two
billion dollars there for lithium
production
environmentalists argue that mining
lithium can require a lot of water and
that chemicals used in production can
leak into nearby water supplies and harm
the surroundings
a rio tinto spokesman even told me that
they're not really going to sacrifice
the big picture for
local concerns one reason some investors
are really bullish moving forward if
protesters and others concerned about
the environmental impact won't let these
companies produce the commodities that
are needed to make the electric vehicles
then
people see higher prices and supply
scarcity and volatility ahead
[Music]